forces now with taking the news about you
do not
to the emergence
of the
world wide web
united european commission has today
to
active
countries in africa
donates
grow
today international of the
more you
to better control of the
back soon as possible that
roosters
protection
unit
cru  vaccination and
this is important because either your
time time for vaccination
a booster shots and finally juropa
station promotions the european
june contract
manufactures it will grow must be
adapted immediately to new balance bay
we take the news about the new
multiple mutated cockpit variant very
seriously  we know that mutations can lead to
new and even more severe variants of the
virus, with the risk
that these will spread further in a few
months.
it is now very important that we in
europe act quickly and in a united
manner. today the european commission proposed
to the member states to apply the emergency brake  activate what r
Concerning iron from the countries in southern Africa and
other affected countries,
all air travel to and from these
countries should be suspended until we have a
clear understanding of how
serious the mutations of this new
variant are and travelers
from these regions returning from these
regions should be subject to strict quarantine
measures  be sure to comply
today i spoke several times with
scientists and the vaccine
manufacturers about this
situation they also fully support these
precautionary measures to prevent a
worldwide spread of this
worrying variant
it also depends very much on all of us to
all citizens please leave it
vaccinate yourself as soon as possible
if you haven't already done
so
upswings offer even
better protection
follow the known rules
to protect yourself from infection we all
know that masks are hand hygiene  ne and
keeping your distance also work contact
tracking travel restrictions and
measures at the borders all of this
helps to slow down the spread of the virus
this is important because
it gives us valuable time valuable
time for further vaccinations and
scolded and in the treaties of the
european union  it
is envisaged by the manufacturers that the vaccine must be quickly
adapted to new variants
as soon as this is necessary europe has
taken
precautions lugano tresor series
lenovo
variable
mutation
[applause]
activity fusion warioware
do
respect
grow
the appeal has grown
update perdu
us-dollar
vaccination protection comparex
social
media  and your propaganda
vaccination
june contract junior ben ali make
novarion detlef aparicio
europe application